- [Kevin] I'm Kevin Carlson,
part of the Worldwide Quick Suite team.
I'm joined by Mary Reese
from Enterprise Engineering.
And Sujit Narapareddy
from our sales operations team.
And we're very excited
to talk to you today
about how Amazon is using Quick Suite.
We're super excited
about all the progress
we've made internally,
and how our employees are using it.
We think there's a lot of lessons
that we can share,
that'll be valuable to all of you.
I'm gonna start by giving you
a little bit of background,
and why we think Quick Suite is important,
especially in this day and age.
There's three main forces
that are driving this workflow place
transformation that we're seeing.
The first obviously
is the emergence of AI agents, right.
So everybody, every company
is starting to think about how agents work
in their business.
And more importantly, how their people
work with agents to get more done.
The second is, there's now a need
for accelerated decision making.
We think that 15% of decisions,
the day-to-day business decisions
that get made in an organization
are going to happen autonomously
in the next three years.
And that's a major shift
in how we all work.
And the rise of these two things,
is pushing us toward more pressure
and competition in our workplace
and with our teams, right.
Individuals that are
taking advantage of agents,
and doing more in an agentic world
are seeing productivity gains,
making it a more competitive place to be.
And all of these things
are driving organizations
to make changes in the way they work.
And our employees feel this, right.
There's an AI consumer presence,
where all of our employees
are using AI in their daily lives.
They're exposed to consumer facing tools,
they see this, they use it,
and they have a desire
to take these same sorts of systems
and use them in the workplace.
But the enterprise
still has the same needs
for security, for reliability,
for a trusted environment.
And so we're seeing this employee desire,
and we know it's going to lead
to more productivity
when they're able to use new tools
balanced by enterprise's needs
for real governance.
And so there's a lot of challenges
taxing your teams,
in this environment we find ourselves in.
They're pulling data
from a variety of different tools.
Many of these tools
have their own agentic environments
for their own natural language chats.
And individuals are having to assemble
all of this information
from different places
to get their job done.
These routine tasks that people do
are preventing them from achieving
higher value work.
Time's wasted.
We know that context switching
is a very large source of friction
in the enterprise workplace,
and people are switching context
in order to get the information they need.
And then when they do have to do
a deeper analysis,
they find themselves in a bottleneck.
Because they have to slow down
and ingest all these
different data sources,
and make a decision
usually with some gravity,
and that slows down the
pace of productivity.
So, our vision with Quick Suite is a place
where agentic teammates work side by side
with your employees,
to quickly answer the
questions that people have.
But not just answer questions,
turn those questions and
answers into actions.
So, we introduced Amazon Quick Suite
on October 9th, we launched Quick Suite.
There's been a a number
of major announcements since.
We're very excited about it,
and we're using it ourselves at Amazon.
It's a place where you can unify
your data sources to get clear
contextually relevant
answers to your questions.
You as an individual
can work in Quick Suite,
but you can do it
increasingly alongside Agentic teammates,
that can help you do more and more.
And we think it's a very
intuitive experience.
And an experience that your company
and your employees are going to love.
So, just a quick rundown
of what Quick Suite is.
If we work from the
bottom up in this chart,
you'll see that Quick Suite aggregates
all of your enterprise data sources
that you need to get your jobs done.
So knowledge bases,
files that individuals
might have access to, and upload.
Maybe they historically stored
in storage somewhere.
And then structured data, from QuickSight.
So, structured data from
your dashboards as well.
We combine this enterprise
knowledge with actions
in first party, third party systems.
And then we augment it,
with World Knowledge
and the ability to search
the web when necessary.
And all of that forms an underpinning
for what Quick Suite allows you to do.
And then we introduce
this concept called, Spaces.
And what spaces is,
it allows Quick Suite rather than to feel
so enterprise heavy and top down,
we're gonna...
As an enterprise, we're gonna structure
knowledge sources and and force you
to use those in rigid way.
Spaces allows teams and individuals
to craft their own environments,
where they can take agentic
actions as they work.
In the middle, here we do this
with all the same things
you've come to love about AWS.
You know, governance, guardrails
or responsible AI perspective.
The ability to have some adherence
to regulatory compliance,
depending on the industry.
And then we overlay
five key capabilities on top of this.
So chat agents, the ability to converse
in natural language to get things done.
A specific agent targeted at research.
So we can do deep research
into complicated business problems,
that require you to aggregate
lots of different data into one answer.
QuickSight the structured data environment
that has all of your BI
and generative BI capabilities.
Flows, which is a lightweight
automation framework
designed for teams and individuals
to agenetically automate
the things they do every day.
And then Quick Automate,
which is a more heavyweight
automation environment
designed for enterprise grade automations.
All of that comes together
to form Quick Suite.
It's built on top of an index, right.
So we bring the structure,
the unstructured,
all that information together,
in a place where we can
look at it uniformly.
That's been a challenge in generative AI.
And now with Agentic workflows,
we need to have a
consolidated underpinning,
where we can make really good decisions
based on all of the organizational data
that matters to us.
So Quick Suite unites teams and agents.
And if you wanna create
a Custom chat agent in Quick Suite,
you don't need to be
a software developer to do it.
You simply use natural language.
You describe the needs of your team,
what you'd like this agent to do.
You can connect it to relevant data sets
that you've uploaded to
get context rich answers.
And Quick Suite will even give you
recommendations on how
to improve that agent
to make it better at the thing
you're designing it to accomplish.
I talked about spaces.
Once you've built an agent in Quick Suite,
you can collaborate with your teammates
in a construct called a Space.
Spaces allow you to build a hub,
where the knowledge that's really relevant
to your team coexists
along with the agents
that your team is going to use.
You can upload specific documents.
Maybe it's project based.
Maybe it's team based,
in order to fit that current mission.
And then you can build agents
that work against only that space.
So they have very
contextually relevant answers
based on information, that's, you know,
current to your team.
One of the challenges, of course,
in organizational agentic AI,
is there is a lot of data.
And so the idea of a space,
allows teams to really hone in
on what's important to them.
Just to dive deeper on
a few of the features
inside Quick Suite,
QuickSight, which you may be familiar
with, hasn't gone anywhere.
It's become a feature inside Quick Suite.
And so all of the structured analyses
that you're used to doing,
interacting with dashboards,
chatting with those dashboards,
using natural language to create
new artifacts off those dashboards,
building data stories,
that all exists in Quick Suite.
And it exists in a very seamless way.
I talked about Quick Research.
Quick research is a place
where you can tackle
those really time intensive tasks.
You can leverage your data,
your organizational data
that you've added into Quick Suite.
You can leverage private third party data.
We recently announced some interesting
third party connections
that allow you to bring
private data sets to
augment your research.
And you can use data from
the internet as well.
And you can combine those
to do a very intensive research project,
that might consider 20
or 30 or 40 sources.
And you can do that in, you know,
as little as 30 minutes.
Quick Flows is the automation engine
that sits inside Quick Suite,
and allows you to connect
all of these tools together.
So you can save time and energy
by automating repetitive tasks.
You create a flow in the same way
that you might have created an agent.
You give a natural language description
about what you're trying to achieve.
Quick Suite will interpret
that description.
It'll look at the things
you have access to.
So, you might have access
to certain data sources, certain spaces
that you or your team have configured.
Certain actions in third party systems.
And Quick Suite will build a flow
that allows you to execute a process.
You'll see some examples
of that later today.
So Amazon Quick Suite kind of in summary
for this introductory section.
Agentic Teammates, a place where you
and those teammates work together.
Those teammates of course,
are going to get more and
more capable over time.
Instantly move from answers to actions
in a seamless way.
And do that in an enterprise grade
secure and governed and reliable place.
Alright, so we know that even though
there are tools like this in existence,
it's very hard to scale.
And I think when I met with customers,
I often would say, well
2025 was, you know,
or 2024 was the year of the pilot,
and 2025 is definitely
gonna be the year of production.
But the reality is it's still very hard.
And 88% of all AI pilots
are still failing to reach production.
And 72% of our C-suite leaders
would say that their company
has faced some challenge
in implementing AI and adopting AI.
This is just the reality
of where we are today.
And at Amazon, we face
this just like all of you.
We are a very peculiar culture.
That's a word we like to use
to describe ourselves.
We have millions of employees worldwide.
We have many, many different organizations
inside of Amazon that
operate very independently.
We have lots and lots of
different job functions.
And it's a very complex environment
in which to implement AI.
And we feel a lot of the same challenges
that you feel.
Just like every enterprise,
these are some of the
challenges that we face.
So, when we implement AI,
it has to be very, very broad.
We want to implement AI in a way
that our all of our organization
can get the most benefit from.
So, we don't wanna
target an individual team
with a very specific product,
that happens a lot in Amazon
due to the creativity of teams,
building things based on the tools
available in AWS.
But what we wanna achieve
is broad organizational adoption.
There's a novelty
associated with AI, right.
And just like you,
we've had to go through the security
and legal processes to get this accepted
in a way that the organization can trust.
And Mary's gonna spend some time talking
about how challenging some of that was.
We also have a lot of disparate data.
We have data silos
just like any other organization.
sitting at the team level,
we have them at the enterprise level.
And in order for Agentic
AI to be effective,
those data silos need to be connected
in a way we can get the right answers
to the questions we're asking.
And finally, we have lots of employees
that are used to doing things
the way they do them.
And we need to implement
some sort of change management
to roll out AI inside the organization.
And that that's a
challenge for us as well.
So, we're excited to tell you,
that Amazonians are using Quick Suite
as their agentic AI teammate.
It's been a journey to get there.
And you're gonna hear about that journey.
But over 40,000 Amazonians
have created custom chat agents
to help them with their job.
Hundreds of thousands of users together
have created over 50,000
quick research queries,
and answered question
s that required deep analysis,
and saved lots of time.
And hundreds of thousands of users
have run over 300,000 quick flows.
Which means somebody's built those flows,
and then they've been executed
over 300,000 times.
So, we're starting to see the benefits
of having rolled out Quick Suite
inside the organization.
And Sujit is gonna share,
go really deep on one of those stories
and why we're seeing so much value.
So with that, I'd like to bring Mary up,
to talk about how challenging this was,
and how successful it was,
to roll out Quick Suite.
Thanks Mary.
- Thank you, Kevin.
I'm Mary Reese, a senior manager
in principle technical product manager,
working on the enterprise
engineering team.
Enterprise engineering is responsible
for delivering enterprise-wide
productivity tools and services
to the organization,
as well as mechanisms to ensure
secure compliance of
our client device fleet.
And what that means,
is that we deliver in support,
first and third party,
large scale roll-outs across Amazon.
We have over a hundred products
in our service catalog.
And some of those products
have as many as a million users.
And so today I'm gonna tell you
about some of the challenges that we had
rolling out Quick Suite
for Amazon internally.
What was in our internal go to market plan
and what best practices we use
to drive engagement.
There were four areas
that we spent a lot of time in,
in order to roll out successfully.
The first one was data unification.
Determining what were the most
valuable data sources to enable
for our customers, Amazon employees
when we started providing usage.
The second one was security.
Amazon has a very high security bar,
and there's a number of steps
that we had to go through
to ensure that our product
met that security bar.
Then there was Privacy.
Being a global company,
we work with a lot of work councils,
and we have to ensure that we meet
their requirements in order
to be able to scale this product
across our entire organization.
And of course scalability.
Anytime we wanna roll out
to such a large user community,
we wanna make sure
that we can drive excitement, engagement,
and get everybody using a product
that's going to benefit them
in the organization as a whole.
So let's dive a little bit deeper
on each one of these challenges.
Starting with Data Unification.
We needed to determine
what were the most valuable data sources
to connect with Quick Suite
to empower our employees,
that would help them
be the most productive.
And so we did some internal research
on what our employees were searching on.
What they were using
for project management.
And what they were using
to collaborate on document creation
and collaboration.
And by looking at the list of products
that were in use,
we prioritized those products
and came up with 15 different products
that we decided to connect to Quick Suite
so our users could access all that data
right within inside of Quick Suite,
creating a curated knowledge base
for our employees to work with.
Next we have the challenge of security.
Amazon has a very high security bar
for products that are used internally.
And there's a specific process
that we go through, to
gain security approvals.
We started by working
with our security partners
to inspect our high level design,
and technical architecture of the product,
as well as threat models.
And we also had to perform
comprehensive penetration testing.
Any findings from the penetration testing
had to be addressed and fixed.
And the testing cycle began again
until we were able to mitigate
all of the risks and get
our security sign off.
Now it doesn't sound like a lot of work
when I phrase it in that way,
but there were a lot of individuals
that did a lot of work
to make it possible to get that approval.
And then of course,
privacy as a global company
is a process to work with
many, many work councils
across all of the different countries
that Amazon does business in.
To help them understand
the risk that is associated with AI.
We actually held a lot
of educational sessions
with the work councils,
educating them on the difference
between Agentic AI and
large language models.
We also put a lot of emphasis on the fact
that employees privacy was protected.
Because data was de-identified.
And that it wasn't being tracked back
to individual employees.
And then another concern
of our work councils
was that the data would
somehow be available
to everybody within Quick Suite.
So we assured them that if an individual
took a data source and put it in a space
like Kevin described, that data source
would inherit the security settings
of the original owner and not be available
for everyone in Quick Suite.
And so by demystifying
exactly what was happening
with privacy settings in Quick Suite.
We're on a path forward to provide access
to everybody in every country
to be able to use Quick Suite.
And then lastly was our scalability plan.
We worked with our legal team
to update our Amazon's
AI responsibility policy,
and ensure that all
employees had access to it.
And then we took a
data-driven research approach,
to understand all the job
families within Amazon,
and where the opportunities
were in pain points
that we could map to features,
that Quick Suite would
provide to the users,
solving those pain points and integrate
that information into our training.
So, we weren't just scaling AI,
but we were providing
solutions for our users,
so they could immediately get started
and be more effective.
And then we created
a multi-point touchpoint launch plan,
with several different ways
of communicating to employees
what was available to them
for the large scale adoption, that we led.
And so we wanted to generate awareness
and excitement throughout the org.
And we kicked off our plan
by automatically installing
Quick Suite browser extension,
and M365 add-ins for Word and Outlook.
So, employees immediately had access
to these tools without doing anything.
Then we launched an email campaign.
We had touchpoints like newsletters.
We launched an internal wiki
with frequently asked questions,
that also included
self-service training, snacks.
Little videos for our employees
to ask questions to and watch,
in case there was something specific
that they were looking
to determine, how to use.
And we also created Slack channels,
where we had individuals assigned
to monitor and respond to questions.
But we found out that a lot of the answers
to the questions,
were actually crowdsourced
by users of Quick Suite themselves.
We conducted dozens of large
live training sessions for users
that we tried to curate to the audience,
and what they would be
using the product for.
And we sent out weekly surveys,
creating a voice of the
customer feedback loop.
So we could incorporate the feedback
that we were getting
into our training materials
and into our communications,
meeting our employees where they are.
And also we created user
community focus groups.
So all those things were part
of how we were going to engage
our user community.
But we needed to start off small.
Because as you know
with a large scale engagement,
you can't just flip it
on like a light switch.
So we gave access to
individual users and AWS,
and enterprise engineering
to our beta version of the product.
And we had a feedback loop
to listen to the voice of the customer
where we took their recommendations
or suggestions, or even
maybe found a few bugs
that we could fix before we gained
a hundred percent confidence
that we were ready to scale this project
to all of our knowledge workers.
And so from there, we looked very deeply
at our user research in our personas
and what their pain points were.
And we determined how we could fit
Quick Suites features
with our user persona pain points.
And so we looked into
each vertical at Amazon,
and then we tried
to look at the data horizontally,
and identify what we
consider a force multiplier.
A solution to the problem
that can be used across
the entire organization.
And we based a lot of our training
around this information.
We identified program status reports
as a force multiplier,
that could drive productivity.
And we were able to do
before and after analysis
to determine how many steps it took
to create a program status report.
The number of times from beginning to end
in our customer, our internal employees
user satisfaction with that process.
We measured our gains in comparison,
and we found out that this was
a very effective force multiplier.
By providing our employees
with data integrations,
that they were able to
create workflows on,
to create status reports.
We saw an improvement
of hours saved per week.
But what we learned is,
it wasn't just a matter
of being able to automate the process
of creating a status report automatically
for a large cross organization
comprehensive report.
By using Agentic AI,
we were also able to gain insights,
and learn things about that report.
So, previously we had been reporting
what we did one week,
and what we were planning
on doing the next week.
Using Quick Suite, we
were able to gain insight
on any work across a large organization
that might be duplicate,
and updates that were missing,
and then also potential risk.
So we were able to elevate the quality
of what we were doing within that.
And so all this to say that the impact
that this product has driven at Amazon,
is that hundreds of thousands
of Amazon employees use Quick Suite today,
as their agentic AI teammate.
And next Sujit is going to tell us
about his team's use of
Quick Suite at Amazon.
- Thank you Mary, for making
Quick Suite available across Amazon,
and for the seamless
enterprise wide integration.
Before we jump into how
we use Quick Suite at AWS
and our AWS Insights journey,
let me introduce myself
and my team's mission.
I'm Sujit Narpareddy, head of Analytics
and Insights at AWS Global Sales.
We support AWS sales,
marketing and services organization.
A team's vision is to deliver
insights and intelligence
to the right persona at the right time
for data driven decision making.
Let's talk about where this all started.
You know, sometimes
understanding the problem
is half the solution.
So, before diving into
the product details,
let me share the challenges we faced,
because I'm sure many
of you would resonate
to the challenges in
your own organizations.
At AWS, like in any other
large metrics enterprise,
we struggle with what I call
the problem of plenty,
with fragmented data sources
and proliferating dashboards.
Our teams were overly focused
on KPIs rather than trying to address
the core business questions.
Most importantly, we found ourselves
unable to effectively analyze root causes
or delivered truly actionable insights.
These challenges were apparent
during the internal business reviews,
and even more prominent
in the rhythm of the business.
This resulted in poor experience
to our C-Suite leaders, sales managers,
during these reviews.
While we had all the necessary
data points and metrics,
they were fragmented and lacked context.
This is similar to having
all the ingredients to prepare a meal
but with no clear recipe
or labels to make sense of them.
From this business review dilemma,
there's almost two critical questions.
First, how could we transform
this overwhelming abundance of data
into meaningful insights,
that can actually drive business value?
And second, how could we evolve
beyond the traditional analytics
to leverage AI-first insights?
These weren't just technical challenges.
They were fundamental to improving
how our business leaders make decision.
With Quick Suite, we
found an elegant solution
to both these questions,
which I'll walk you through next.
To answer these questions,
we developed a three-tiered approach.
Rather than throwing
more and more dashboards at the problem,
we needed a structured approach,
that transforms how we think about data.
Think of this as a journey,
from knowing to understanding to acting.
It starts with descriptive analytics.
Answering what is
happening in the business.
It gives us the baseline metrics
and data points, but we didn't stop here.
Moving to the second tier.
Diagnostic Analytics.
This is where we dig
deeper into understanding
why, and where this is happening.
This is crucial because,
it moves us beyond just
supporting the trends,
to actually understanding the root cause.
For example, instead of just seeing
a dip in sales, we can pinpoint exactly
where and why that dip occurred.
The final tier, Prescriptive Analytics.
This is what sets this framework apart.
It answers the critical question,
how can we take action?
This is where our AI powered insights
truly shine.
Instead of leaving the user
to interpret the data,
the system provides
clear actionable recommendations
based on proven patterns
and predictive analytics.
The ultimate goal here,
isn't just to tell users what's happening,
it's to guide them on
what to do about data.
Now, let me show you
how we brought this framework to life.
AWS Insights, is our analytics platform,
which facilitates business
reviews within AWS.
This combines traditional
business intelligence
with modern AI capabilities,
providing users flexible ways
to interact with business data.
The two capabilities are,
one, Traditional Analytics,
with Quick Suite Dashboards.
But with a twist, to
embed these dashboards
on a web application.
Making analytics more accessible,
collaborative and actionable
for everyone in your enterprise.
This allowed us to go from CEO to seller,
services to sales and marketing to signal,
all at one place.
Two.
Conversation AI with quick chat.
Letting users ask
questions in plain English,
and giving them faster and deeper answers,
all in less than minutes.
Now to put this concepts into action,
and give you a better
visual understanding,
let's watch a short demonstration.
- [Narrator] As leaders managing
AWS's complex business,
we needed a solution
that could keep pace with our scale
and decision making speed.
AWS Insights is our answer.
A platform that transforms
how we analyze and act
on business insights
across our organization.
We've structured this platform
around how we run our business.
Central Insights mirror
our business review cadences.
While functional and supplemental insights
serve our specialized teams.
This isn't just another set of dashboards,
it's built around our operational rhythm
with context and guardrails
embedded at every layer.
For traditional analytics,
three key capabilities
make this powerful for our leaders.
First, Quick Sight Embedding allows us,
to have a navigation pain and shortcuts.
Second, seamless context preservation.
As your filters and actions follow you,
eliminating the need to rebuild context
across dashboards.
Third, instant drill downs
from CEO level metrics,
to individual customer performance,
revealing exactly what's
driving anomalies.
For the conversational experience,
our data structure and approach
to knowledge modeling,
allows quick suite chat agents
to understand our business context.
I can ask, provide me a business summary,
and get actionable
and contextualized insights immediately.
A summary like this before,
would've required manual requests,
a review across multiple dashboards.
And not to mention the meetings Q and A,
plus the back and forth
to understand all of the unique details.
Sales leaders can now
dive as deep as they want,
with natural language conversations,
that respect not only their permissions,
but also their unique
context and sales strategy.
The chat agent also allows
web search to connect
to external intelligence.
Leaders can ask, analyze industry trends
that may impact our December forecast,
to get web source
insights securely grounded
in our actual business performance.
This platform solves
what we've struggled with for years.
Handling massive data at scale,
while ensuring every leader
works from the same source of truth,
with no more conflicting numbers
across sales, finance, and operations.
This is how we run AWS
at the speed our business
and customers demand.
- As you've seen in the demo,
the dashboards and the AI interactions
work together seamlessly
to deliver insights.
But what you're seeing,
is just the tip of the iceberg.
To create this intuitive experience,
to build a comprehensive foundation
with three key elements.
Now, let me take you behind the scenes
to show you our approach.
First, how we enhance
the traditional insights
to make them more actionable.
Second, how did we prepare the AI engine
to deliver intelligent
and contextual responses?
And third, how we connected everything
through Quick Suite,
to create a unified experience.
Let's dive into each of these areas
and see how we work them together.
Let's look into this
problem of proliferation.
When we started, dashboards
existed in silos,
like the example on the screen.
They were duplicate revenue
dashboards by region,
and users access
separate dashboards in isolation.
There was no unified structure
connecting this insights,
leading to the fragmented experience.
So, to address this,
we consolidated all these dashboards.
On a Quick Suite covered web application,
using a book like architecture,
like you're seeing on the screen.
This book like architecture has chapters
representing a specific
function of the business.
Like revenue, customer analytics,
operations and finance.
All of them connected
through a unified software layer.
The book like architecture approach,
means that each business
has its own dedicated chapter
with relevant dashboards.
But, they're all interconnected
through the common underlying foundational
data and software layer.
This ensures consistency
in insights and user experience.
Quick Suites web application layer,
allowed us to systematically
control the experience.
And also at the same time
provide the flexibility
for builder community to co-develop.
Now let's dive into how we prepared
the AI engine with a five step flywheel
Question to the audience here.
Raise your hands if you've
ever been frustrated
by an agent giving you
irrelevant or incomplete responses.
Quite a few hands raised to yourself.
That's exactly what we're trying to solve
with knowledge base, with quick agents.
Agents configured on a dashboard
is like a vending machine.
When you push a button,
you exactly get a very specific item.
However, a knowledge base
agent is like a chef.
It has the capability
to create custom solutions
from all the available ingredients.
This knowledge base back agents
are far more powerful.
But it requires some initial setup,
and some configuration.
We've invested in building
this knowledge base
for our sophisticated architecture,
to ensure it meets our complex use case.
So we began with
centralizing the data stores,
and implementing pre-calculated metrics.
And building evaluation frameworks
with checkpoints to catch
agent hallucinations.
These built-in validations
ensure responses
are accurate and reliable.
Our secret ingredient here,
is to maintain business
logic and relationships
through template structure.
This uses the much needed
context preservation.
Now moving to the enrichment phase.
In an enterprise setting, it's very common
that each department like sales,
marketing, finance, to
traditionally maintain
their own data systems.
When we start, we want agents to give
comprehensive insights.
They're limited by these
artificial boundaries.
So, we implemented
a cross vertical data enrichment
with smart chunking.
In case of large data sets,
that intelligently segmented
into manageable chunks,
with business relationships
established across departments.
This isn't a one-time setup,
it's a living iterative
enrichment process,
to keep the data base
and the knowledge base current
across all business functions.
Quick flows, built in functionality
helps with orchestrating
the entire enrichment process.
Now that we have a powerful knowledge base
enriched with cross-functional data,
let me show you something
that's truly game changing.
How we move from asking,
what happened to understanding
how and why it happened.
Imagine a very common business question.
How is this month's revenue performance?
In the past, the three user roles
that you can see on the screen,
let's say executive, sales and finance,
would see the same static answer
on the dashboard.
Today, each receives insights tailored
specifically for their role.
And this magic happens by combining
knowledge base with quick agents,
delivering instant and
personalized intelligence.
While the knowledge base provides
business context and
semantic understanding,
the Quick Agents act as
the intelligent analyst
to perform root cause analysis,
and explaining the why behind the trends.
That's how we are making data intelligence
truly personal and
actionable for every persona.
it's not just about the question,
but it's also about who
is asking the question.
Moving to security phase.
Here's a challenge that we all face.
How do you share sensitive business data
with thousands of users,
while ensuring everyone
only sees what they are supposed to see?
We created a low level
security architecture layer
that handles this problem.
The smart system filters data
based on our user persona
before it leaves the database.
Think of this as your digital bouncer.
Ensuring unauthorized information
never makes it past the database store.
Now that we have secured our data,
let's talk about bringing together
organization weight collective expertise.
Within AWS, different teams
have built specialized agents.
each bringing unique capabilities
from customer success workflows
to financial modeling.
We wanted to leverage
these existing agents,
to enrich our platform without
building them from scratch.
Here's where quick actions
provide a solution.
It acts as a universal translator,
letting these specialized agents
work together securely.
Think of this as an
intelligent orchestrator,
ensuring all our expert systems
speak the same language
while respecting the security boundaries.
With this setup,
we just didn't connect the agents.
We broke down the walls between the teams,
and created a truly
collaborative AI ecosystem.
Let me bring this all together.
What you're seeing here,
is the complete architecture
of AWS Insights, AI
engine with Quick Suite.
Now let's move on to how do we connect
with Quick Suite.
There are three primary
methods to connect,
depending on the use case.
For experimentation,
we can use out of the
box Quick Knowledge Base.
This is perfect for prototyping,
testing new ideas,
and this requires minimal to no coding.
Two.
For task automation,
especially when connecting
multiple applications,
we can expose business focused tools
as MCP endpoints to connect
with Quick Suites Agent.
This efficiently handles
the routine tasks,
and is also another out
of the box solution.
Three.
For business narratives
or for any other complex
reasoning use cases.
Building a knowledge base
like we've discussed earlier,
helps and can be connected
via MCP connection.
Before I wrap up, I want to share
the critical lessons we learned
along this journey.
Because building a five
star culinary experience
isn't just about having
the right ingredients and equipment.
It's about the principles and practices
to ensure consistent excellence.
So lesson one.
Invest in your data.
Your agent is only as good as your data.
We've learned early that
you can't compensate for poor data
with a more powerful AI model.
Two.
Understand your user and their intent.
One size fits all insights won't work.
We need our agents to
understand who's asking,
not just what they're asking.
Three.
Right information beats all information.
More data doesn't mean better answers.
So prioritize precision over volume.
Four.
Catch errors before deployment.
Because quality is non-negotiable.
We implemented Evolution frameworks
with checkpoints to catch
agent hallucinations
before they reach customers.
Built in Validations ensures responses
are accurate and reliable.
Now I'll welcome Kevin
back onto the stage,
to share some other customer examples.
- Thanks Sujit.
I love this example,
because it's weighty, right.
It shows enterprise grade thinking.
It doesn't ignore the data preparation.
It shows how a real enterprise at scale
can surface something through Quick Suite.
That takes a lot of
work behind the scenes.
But then because of
what Quick Suite offers,
provides a much better experience
to the people using those tools.
So, I think it's a great example.
Not every example is that weighty.
And so I wanna walk
through some other ways
that Amazon is benefiting from Quick Suite
throughout the organization,
and just share some
other examples for you.
So our AWS finance team has been
one of the early adopters of Quick Suite.
They track a number of deals across
a lot of disconnected data sources.
So they use, you know,
four hours typically
to do a deal analysis.
They bring data together from a variety
of disparate systems to do that.
And what they wanted to do,
was short circuit that time.
And so they implemented Quick Suite,
they built space that
has the knowledge bases
that they need to bring
those disparate data sources together.
And now they see analysis
going from four hours down to minutes.
They're running 500 concurrent deals
at the same time, which is more scale
than they could achieve before.
They have implemented real time alerts,
to be proactive, when things
are not going the way
they want them to go.
And the end result here,
is acceleration of
revenue for the business.
Our worldwide specialist team,
that's the team that I'm on.
You might see the jackets
with WWSO on them around.
The worldwide specialist team,
is a group of experts
that support our field,
because they have real deep knowledge
into the services or industries
that AWS works in.
And so the challenge there is,
that there's a lot of fragmented content.
There's manual artifacts created all over.
It's very hard to prep for a meeting,
especially if you're trying to operate
across a variety of
services that AWS offers.
There's lots of material.
And so the solution for the WWSO team,
has been to build a unified data mesh
that's exposed through Quick Suite.
It uses MCP, and some of
the connected actions,
and it basically allows them to automate
that briefing and preparation process.
And so they're seeing a 90% reduction
in time spent to create
what we would call a sales play.
Over 10 hours saved a week
for people that were spending
a lot of time creating materials
in advance of meetings.
We're seeing 75% of the workforce engage
with those natural
language chat companions,
in this, you know,
human plus agent inside Quick Suite.
The way they work together.
And actually seeing a much better result
in terms of coverage of
that source material.
In supply chain by Amazon,
the finance team there has also seen
great value in Quick Suite.
So there were six legacy companies
that consolidated to become
that supply chain organization.
And that meant there's a lot
of disparate fragmented systems
behind the scenes, that they need to use
to get their work done.
And so they implemented Quick Suite.
Again knowledge base space,
consolidate that information together.
And now when they build
strategic finance documents,
they see an incredible increase
in their writing velocity,
because they don't have to go
to those six individual places
from six legacy organizations
to pull information together.
They've been able to
expand internationally
in a more efficient way.
And they can do lots of on demand analysis
that they didn't have the time
or bandwidth to complete before.
The last example is Quick Scribe.
So as you can imagine,
when we meet with customers,
and we sit down with you,
we take lots and lots of meeting notes,
and we have lots and lots of insights
that we gather, but oftentimes
those are not aggregated
in a meaningful way.
And so, a team built something
called Quick Scribe
that sits on top of Quick Suite,
and this allows us to
extract and structure
all of that unstructured content
into something that is more meaningful
for us moving forward.
So, we can capture
documentation instantly.
We can start to recognize patterns
that we couldn't see before.
And we really have a centralized
source of intelligence
from all those conversations
we have with our customers
that are so valuable to
us here at at Amazon.
So there's lots of these examples,
and our commitment to you,
is that we are going to do our best
to share these publicly,
to make them available,
because we're learning things every day.
For myself, you know,
sitting on the Worldwide Quick Suite team,
I haven't been able to anticipate
any of the ways in which the business
is really getting the most value.
And so over time as we can,
we'll document more and more of these,
and we'll share them publicly.
We'll try to use our
lessons as an organization,
to help you in your journey
as you adopt Quick Suite.
We have a full packed re-Invent here
with Quick Suite Sessions.
There are 25 total sessions.
There were several yesterday.
Today there are still a couple more.
I think there's a Chalk Talk coming up.
There's a 5:00 PM workshop.
We encourage you to attend these.
We have seven sessions on Wednesday.
Another seven sessions on Thursday.
So please, you know,
take a look at the catalog,
and use this opportunity
to get to know Quick Suite,
and what you can do with it.
There is so much depth
in each of those functions
and research and automated flows,
that it's worth attending
some of these to learn more.
Couple of QR codes, I'll leave up here
for a minute that you can scan.
We have a Quick Suite community.
That is a public facing site,
that has tons and tons of resources.
It has an engaged community of people
that contribute and answer questions.
You can join that Quick Suite community.
There are demos you can run up there.
It is our home.
Our public facing home
for all things Quick Suite.
So please take advantage of that.
And then you can continue
your learning journey
on AWS Skill builder.
So as you learn more about...
Or you desire to learn
more about Agentic AI,
and how Quick Suite
fits into that picture,
you can use Skill Builders, a place to go,
with over a thousand
free expert led training classes.
So we really appreciate your time today.
I hope you have a wonderful rest
of your re:Invent.
Thank you very much.